we're live at e3 2014 Sean McGinnis up
on the GameSpot stage and I've got
Thomas from CI games who's here to show
us a little bit of Lords of the Fallen
Thomas we're gonna go ahead and just
jump straight into it because we've got
a guy off stage who has been very
patiently playing the game knighted
States yeah that's true a few sentences
about what the game is yeah for we
actually go into the very tiny technical
details of the gameplay for those who
are interested hey it's an action RPG so
we're trying to mix the game that bases
on quite complex and strategic of combat
system and a game that has interesting
and captivating story but we definitely
wanted to make sure that one of these
sides is more prominent so it's a game
primarily focused on the gameplay
experience right still it's a fantasy
world and there is a legend that we've
crafted particularly for this game to
make it interesting there's a legend
about a fallen god humanity have
defeated him thousands of years ago and
they believe they can do really really
big and epic things because of what
they've achieved they believe they can
for example eradicate evil out of human
nature completely whether that's
reasonable or not we're not gonna give
right they believe they can do it and
because of that they punish everyone who
commits deadly sins with to chewing them
across the face and when the game starts
I'm gonna give you the get-go the
beginning of the game not to spoil the
rest right right of course when a game
starts the demons the army of the Fallen
God starts to reappear nobody knows why
but it's only natural for people as I've
described them to think we don't fight
them let's see bow
so we'll face these evil demons with the
worst side of our human nature so they
find a guy who's committed the most the
most deadly sins out there and that's
her hero that's harken to two - all
across the face and I'm gonna I'm not
gonna lie to anybody he's not a good
person
yeah it's a guy who's done a lot of bad
things but he's predestined to do what's
ahead of him and he's capable of doing
what it takes to defeat demonic army and
that's pretty much the beginning of the
game
let's pretty much the premise the start
of it and yeah while Steve is playing in
the background I can tell you what's
going on he's actually using some of the
clerics base
right now gear is not bound to your
class when you start a game when you
select the class of a character you
pretty much lock down the type of spells
that you're gonna be using so anything
anything else like the gear that you
have or the way that you crafted or the
attributes of your character that's
totally independent of the class this
guy is a big right now this some people
will consider him any mini boss but
there is an easy way to commit to defeat
this guy there you go
of course if he drops anything you won't
get it right or your consideration as a
player but you might try the easy way
out and it's especially important for us
because we believe that Lords of the
Fallen can be a very challenging game
for people who seek challenge but at the
same time we put a lot of work in trying
to remove the elements that for
especially for the mainstream audience
might feel like something frustrating
especially at the opening hours of the
game
so environmental deaths the frequency of
the checkpoints in the game and a lot of
stuff like that we've actually tried to
make sure that it's gonna be slightly
more widening the type of audience a lot
of very challenging games have it's it's
probably the biggest challenge ahead of
the day this is what we're after so you
know looking at the game right now
seeing these you know tough looking
enemies and very careful deliberate
movements yeah most of the fights are
one-on-one
yeah actually learning particularly
ponent is the basis the foundation of
fun in this game I believe so I mean
with that you get like kind of an
immediate Dark Souls kind of a feel is
it fair to say that you guys are fans of
that series but trying to do something
there it's sure I would be cheating it
would be ungrateful I would be stupid
not to deny that work so it's definitely
one of the the soul series so yes a
definitely one of the inspirations but I
think there are a lot of differences in
Roth's a lot of things that make it
stand out on its own the people will not
think that it's a bad thing and
inspiration is not a bad thing it
doesn't have to be and because of that I
believe that playing Lords the Fallen is
going to be it's going to be based
around one of the most interesting
things that challenging games like souls
for example gave people the sense of
satisfaction the sense of reward but at
the same time it's not going to be
frustrating I hope I believe we're
trying
right right of course so in case you
guys have any questions about Lords of
the Fallen shoot you can send them my
way in the GameSpot chat let's actually
I'm curious about you mentioned in check
points game how did it how does the
check point system work extra Steve is
just next to one of the check points as
you can see that the red chard in here
it's not working when enemies are near
but the interesting thing is they are
not placed only like in the beginning of
the location you won't have to be
backtracking a whole location when you
die close to the boss fight and
interesting mechanics that we have for
the safe points is that you can actually
bank the XP that you have on you when
you're next to the checkpoint so when
you die just after that you're not gonna
be losing that and also you don't have
to commit to buying certain points of
your attributes or upgrading your
spell's at any given time because when
you have will have banked your XP you
can for example wait until the boss
fight and try to make up your mind what
the best strategy is and use that
upgrade that you have booked until then
back at that time I think it's you know
it's one of these things that will make
people the most important thing one of
the most but one of the most important
things for us and rose upon was to try
to distribute the learning process
across the span of time that people will
want you can actually as a player you
can decide how long you want to take to
learn the mechanics of the game all
right let's see here Stevie's almost at
the boss by just one less spider to
defeat I know a lot of ping a lot of
people think that calling this a spider
is a little bit of an exaggeration but
still if you leave the spider alone for
too long it's gonna be laying eggs
they're gonna be hatching small spider
like this yeah a little baby spider yeah
it's just getting a little bit more
difficult if you leave spider alone so
it's it's probably advised to try to
deal a lot of damage in short amount of
time to try to deal with them fast
and I also believe that Steve is gonna
be trying to tackle the boss that is
just up ahead and the boss that we're
gonna see champion as we call him it's
an interesting one because he's got a
rage mode that he gets well there's a
bar there's the progress when he deals a
lot of damage to the player a short
amount of time he can get really really
angry it gets he starts to be a flame
his blades that they have on the hands
starts to be a flame and it gets a whole
lot more difficult than so but there's a
there's a symmetry there's a there's a
there's a reverse mechanics in that
because if you deal a lot of the damage
to the boss you get to stun him if you
deal even more you get to stand him
again and that second stun is longer and
so on and so on and so on so there's a
particular reflection in the way you
fight with this boss I think it's a cool
thing so just got a couple minutes left
here but I do want to ask you a question
about the classes I believe you
mentioned that this is the cleric Steve
is using cleric gear so to say in here
but the most important thing is that
there are spells that determine sort of
your class at the beginning of the game
so if you wanted to turn three classes
of spell trees if you want to choose a
cleric most of the spells will be like
regenerative yeah if you want to use
rogue it's probably gonna be about quick
and fast assassination style of fighting
if you want to choose warrior you're
gonna be down in like brawling through
enemies and having high damage even if
you say you can take a hit and that is
one thing in the other thing because
there are three pillars of character
development as I mentioned the second
one is attributes and the third one is
gear that the armors and shields and the
weapons these are class independent so
technically what we could say that Steve
is right now he's using a cleric gear
and he's using one of the warrior spells
and here that the RAM de the the running
very strong and powerful project that
he's shooting maybe that's maybe it
could go to battle mage you know there's
there's like a mix that you can create
your own there you go one the spells
all right pretty much let's see if Steve
can oh you got hit that's the little
TTIP can defeat the the champion bus if
not it's probably going to be trying
again also you will then notice that it
that it won't take him nice Dodge that
it won't take him a whole occasion to
backtrack it to get to the bar a and
because you're respond quite close to
the boss arena well unfortunately my
producers are telling me that we're
running out of time here so bad right
sorry Steve I made it all this way and
then we're going to remove you from your
moment of glory
but let's sum it up Lords the fallen yes
coming out this fall we're definitely
don't to be one of these games that
slips into 2015 we're coming up this
fall 2014 on PC PlayStation 4 and Xbox
one we're a next-gen game and I really
think you can tell by watching at the
game a lot of time and work we've
invested in Lea packs and the clots and
then you know we really believe that a
lot of the power that that is in the
next-gen platforms has given us
opportunity to make this game look so
good and with our direction that we have
more of a high an epic fantasy I should
say rather than dark and greedy so yeah
that's pretty much look so cool Thomas
thank you so much really appreciate you
swinging by the guys that was Lords of
the Fallen